hey guys Anna and Dave back at
Roseanne's kitchen table and we're still
breaking down the top stories of the
year and I wanted to go to the NSA on
this one because they're probably
watching this right all right I hope
they were watching there at least one I
hopefully at least watch the ad on so
then I say really broke not a 2014 it
broke sort of in the middle of 2013 or i
guess the summer of two thousand
thirteen and you know there was that
whole james clapper thing i did we don't
wittingly spy as he was scratching his
head and we all knew he was lying of
course but I in a weird way I think this
story was actually inspiring this year
because i think people actually kind of
woke up to what the government's doing
woke up to like having their own privacy
actually attacked woke up to a little
bit of you know feeling the need to own
their so i think there was
something kind of inspiring as
disturbing as the whole thing is and it
keeps leaking we keep always hearing
more so yeah i mean i wish i could agree
with you but i feel like people still
don't take that massive violation of our
freedom and our rights seriously yeah
anytime you have a discussion about the
Second Amendment people are up in arms
anytime you have a discussion about our
privacy rights you still have a huge
chunk of the American population that
says nods for national security it's not
that big of a deal i'm not doing
anything wrong so if the government
wants to spy on me who cares i I can't
stand those arguments right but they're
still being made um also this year has
been a really big in my opinion negative
year when it comes to privacy issues
because a lot of people were in support
of the hackers that leaked those new
celebrity pictures and that was wrong
yeah but I don't know I think that we
don't value privacy as much as we claim
we do yeah so I guess so I'm with you so
I'm part of me is trying to just find
that some people have woken up to it but
yeah the bulk of the stuff obviously is
is bad stuff um I I hope we're turning a
corner here do you think or is it or is
it just like we're too far gone at this
point like we all have snapchat
Instagram a bubble like we're all just
putting this stuff out there new apps
just keep coming so it's like you're not
gonna stop and they're not gonna stop
yeah I mean we're all guilty of
oversharing I know that I overshare but
I do
information that I'm comfortable with
people knowing I'm not comfortable with
the government spying in on what type of
porn i watch and I'm definitely not
comfortable with them utilizing that as
a tool of intimidation which I think
they want to do if the government knows
that they have just ways have the fear
of it you know you me like they do I
think they do I mean if you know the
government is keeping a close eye on you
has all this data has records of your
phone conversations they claim it's me
at meta data I don't believe that for a
second um they know kind of websites or
visiting they have all this dirt on you
are you really gonna want to be
politically active it sounds
conspiratorial but I don't think it's
crazy I mean the government utilized the
strategy when it came to these six
Muslim individuals living abroad they're
like okay well we think that they might
be extremists how can we discredit them
yeah why don't we follow the type of
porn that they're watching and spread
that information to the people that
believe in them right and the same type
of strategy could be used on American
citizens yeah it's endlessly scary it's
sort of we're in like some sort of
sci-fi future thing where we know it's
happening and it's like what do we do at
the same time so of course the other and
probably the biggest story of the year
and the one that's going to be the
biggest leading into 2015 was the
Ferguson story Mike Brown shooting and
then of course Eric garner in New York
we're still like right in the midst of
the throes of this thing I mean just
yesterday at one of the officers
funerals then why PD turned their back
on Mayor Bill de Blasio it's a horrible
story all around as you know I the
garner one to me like the the mike brown
one at some level I guess they're still
with some conflicting reports of what
happened and yet and that's one of the
things because I don't trust anyone in
the media anymore I read all these
stories and I'm like I don't know what
to believe anymore they say oh there was
evidence of a fight you know like just
all this stuff but the garner one was so
obvious to me I just this man should not
have been dead under any circumstances
generated me like that's not how this
thing should have went down yeah um the
Eric garner story in particular really
depressed me okay and that one of the
reasons why was because you did have
surveillance and you see this guy who's
just pleading with the cops to leave him
alone the reason why Eric garner was
there was because he had broken up a
fight the cops showed up
up and Eric garner apparently in the
past has sold loose cigarettes he have
any loose cigarettes on him at the time
but nonetheless the cop decided he's
gonna harass them anyway aerogarden
harassed by the cops so many times that
he was pleading with them please just
leave me alone this stops today right
and the cop waited for backup and they
put some in a chokehold need eyes and
people make the argument that Eric
garner was unhealthy and that's the
reason why he died no what triggered
Eric Garner's death was the fact that a
cop felt the need to harass and after he
broke up a fight and then put his ass in
a choke hold until he died okay so
that's what the real issue is here how
does anyone watch that video and make
any justification for what went down and
that's the thing that's made me
depressed this year over doing what I do
I'm getting heated right I have to deal
with that feedback it up really did we
watch the same video this is ridiculous
so that okay so that's an interesting
play setting to go with this like how so
everyone watches the same stuff and this
is what I'm fascinated especially on
Twitter where people watch the same
videos you know you mean they see the
same things and then everyone jumps on
their partisan side yeah and this goes
in almost every topic that we talk about
ever now that's what i'm seeing people
ignore facts and truth and they just
always they don't want to do anything
that doesn't support their you know
presuppose notions or whatever um i know
you try not to do that I and I I try not
to do it but it's hard to it's really
urgent see any of that the meteorite
were very real critical I know a lot of
people will disagree with this because
there's this notion that I'm extreme in
my views but I'm really not I'm when I'm
given evidence that states the contrary
to what I believe I will be the first to
raise my hand be like you know what I
was wrong I've done that with drug
legalization I've done that with
prostitution uh when we did the story of
the you know European scientist who
helped uh land a probe on a moving
comment uh I spoke out against a lot of
feminists that were angry because he was
wearing a shirt that had like cartoon
that were naked right and so a lot of
people were shocked because they're like
but you're a feminazi I'm not a feminazi
I use common sense when it comes to my
commentary maybe sometimes people don't
agree with me but it's important to
challenge your own view
points just because someone identifies
as a feminist doesn't mean that they
should call everything sexist when other
feminists do do you agree with this
feminazi let us know in the comments
what do you think of these stories how
we covered them how the media covered
them all that good stuff yeah comment
and subscribe and all that good stuff